it was solely my idea to record he
didn't seek to impress a certain
demographic he wanted to do this and we
did I'm glad we did so people see the
real side of him regarding in shahada we
agreed it shouldn't be shown on a
podcast
or anything because the people will
claim us for clout or fake following
them
a lot of brothers and sisters have been
flooding our DMS with our thoughts on
this Andrew Tate reverting accepting
Islam did he convert did he not and we
got some thoughts for that inshaallah so
let's jump right into it
foreign
so before we go on as you guys can see
around me you can see this too you know
clearly it's Andrew Tate it's not
someone else
um praying Salah in a Masjid and this is
what happens
so the the brother who's Tick Tock that
this was posted from I think he's like
an MMA athlete or something like that
the brother says brother Andrew is very
sincere and his heart is with Islam let
me clarify a few things why did I record
us pray
because it helps to post positivity I
guess guys it's nice then he says rather
than post-materialistic as I myself have
been guilty of or waste time on things
he could have said no he knows this can
also have a negative effect to his
already controversial status on social
media but he did this for himself
it was a private visit to the Masjid
just me and him and he wanted that we
planned it days ago but he actually
reminded me today to go
then he says it was my it was it was
solely my idea to record he didn't seek
to impress a certain demographic he
wanted to do this and we did I'm glad we
did so people see the real side of him
well I spent a lot it's a way to
motivate the younger kids not be ashamed
of being religious and praying respect
this more
respect this more than how tough you are
or how much money you have etc etc can't
really see the very bottom but I'll read
whatever is left inshaallah no I'll just
play it bro this was the first time in a
mosque
um and what a way to start his journey
um and then let's see here
I'll ask you regarding shahada we agreed
it shouldn't be shown on the podcast
or anything because the people will
claim us for clout or fake following
nobody is perfect but alhamdulillah the
guy is a good heart of your intentions
he is mobbed by people 24 7 financially
super wealthy and has all the perks uh a
man dreams of it's fairly true
but on the Saturday night we both went
to Masjid to pray spoken like about the
Quran Hadith how the prophet behaved the
misconceptions of Islam and more
masha'allah so to all those speaking
about the shahada and all please a lot
of the brother just to announce someone
he wants and allow him to take his time
change of Lifestyle isn't a fast thing
but to accept the truth and believe it
is vital as we all know tomorrow is
never guaranteed PS to those saying uh
his praying technique is wrong seriously
get a life it's his first time and even
if he isn't fully even
and even that he is fully concentrated
in an Oscar intellectual question
wow man
wow this is why I included this because
a lot of people don't know about this
and it was posted from uh this brother
I'm just gonna put it at the end right
here that's his Tick Tock Tam Khan
um he's the one that has been posting
all this so Nami bro before we even go
right into it I want to know your
thoughts on this stuff awesome I
honestly it's crazy because
when I first saw the video Everything
the brother put I was kind of thinking
of I'm like Yanni okay if this is for
clout you know most of them shouldn't
talk about it and if this is legit which
we should assume the best and assume
that is legit you know at least at the
Forefront then people should just like
leave him alone people should let him be
as soon as people are like you know
trying to get the answer trying to make
it public you're going to have all these
different types of groups of people
coming after them some for interviews
some to you know teaching about Islam
something critique them something to be
like now you need to do this and give
them a list of 50 things he has to do
cut this thing off this uh wealth's
Haram these women is gonna try and
change his whole life in a day
subhanallah and it's not going to be
good for anyone right I'm sure he's a
strong guy but I don't think even he can
handle something like that everyone
coming at him and saying you know you
need to do this and that in regards to
his faith you know I might it might
Shake him a little bit so I'm very glad
that the brother did that alhamdulillah
and I noticed that that it seems to be
the case that Andrew J has a lot of
Muslims around them alhamdulillah which
I think is beautiful and also recently
we saw that Muhammad hijab he posted
that he did an interview with Andrew
Tate alhamdulillah so maybe that also
had a uh a big impact because it seemed
it seemed the chronology of it seems to
be that they spoke Muhammad Jabba and
Tate spoke together and then after that
he went to frame the Masjid because I
think he was already uh I think he's
been in Dubai recently
hence the you know I'm going to the
Masjid and praying the brother and all
that stuff so
those are my thoughts man I agree with
the brother 100 I think he should keep
this private keep it to himself and then
when he is solid and firm in his faith
inshallah whenever he wants if he wants
I don't know if he's taking a shot there
or not you know regardless I hope he
doesn't show Allah he can come out to
the public and let the people know
um and I hope that the Muslims will
basically receive him well be proper
Muslims behave themselves and I hope
that the behaved Muslims will critique
the unbehaved Muslims um who say
anything negative against them
there's not much else that I wanted to
add in bro you said it perfectly and may
Allah bless you for that there is one
thing too that I wanted to touch on and
a lot of people that are like personal
people in my life you know in my circle
when they've been texting me what are
your thoughts I've been telling them bro
Allah Allah knows best it's not up to us
to judge what's in someone's heart bro
and I I did want to address something I
was talking to brother wahabro you know
the Warner yesterday over uh you know I
was going outside to uh get some food
and in the car I was just you know
sending voice memos he was sending me
voicemails back and forth
um wow bro if you're watching this I've
been extremely busy bro so I'm gonna go
on my phone inshallah soon and respond
but we were talking about this extreme
in people today regarding this situation
so there's a lot of people already here
like Andrew Tate's fake he's a cloud
chaser he's he's just doing this reviews
and publicity and then you see the Other
Extreme kind of simping for Andrew Tate
you know throwing dollars at him and
being like yo convert to Islam bro
convert we need your approval we need
this and I'm just like bro why is there
such a like a split between how we
should be and everyone's on one extreme
I'm not gonna name any any of these
brothers inshallah but I've seen a lot
of people mention on YouTube and
Instagram and all this oh he did not
convert he's never going to convert he's
just using it for this bro you're never
gonna know what's in their heart you
won't I'm sure of course you know I see
where you guys are coming from too
because let's be honest you know he's
been on fresh and fit for months now
saying if I had to bet on one religion
it would have to be Islam Romney how
many times have we looked at this clip
you know but it's like if you're betting
bro you are betting Liquor on me said
you know so you are kind of gambling
with life now so you really should
accept it
um but then you're still Christian you
know so it doesn't make sense you've
been talking but I get it you know it's
a lifelong journey but the other you
know extreme of the people I don't like
them too where they're are kind of like
you know what
um we need Andrew Tate's approval we
need Jordan Peterson to convert you know
as if them doing it increases Allah in
the site so stuck for Allah bro if every
single person in this Dunya if everyone
was on point bro with their Islam it
wouldn't increase Allah in even the
slightest bro if everyone was going
against Allah disobeying Allah living
the most immoral life bro according to
Islam it wouldn't decrease Allah in the
slightest bro so why are we out here
looking for cosines from these secular
you know celebrities and influencers bro
like it means anything
yeah that's that's a beautiful Point bro
it's parallel you just kind of reminded
me of
of something grave I think which is you
know on the day of judgment regardless
of what these people become Muslim or
not you will see every single person you
will see Jordan Peterson you'll see
Andrew Tate you'll see his brother
you'll see every single person basically
standing there in shock and awe and full
submission of Allah when Allah and the
rose and the rose and the rose of angels
come everyone will be in submission
everyone will look up like I don't know
what the heck is going to happen to me
imagine like looking up to Someone Like
Jordan Peterson and you see the look in
his face on the day of judgment and
you're like whoa I can't believe you
know I was basically waiting for this
guy to accept Islam and then I was going
to do this and you know like if you live
in such an extreme so
I think
I think the more attention you give
someone in regards to them being Muslim
the words that actually becomes
and I think if anything these people are
fueling a negative view of Islam in
these people's lives I think both ends
are because you have one and that's
going to be like you know from the very
beginning he's Faking It and then on the
other end they put so much pressure on
him being Muslim that if he doesn't then
they're going to join the other side and
say oh he was faking it and then he's
just gonna look like a bad guy and as
someone who's been scrutinized already
so much on the internet I'm not going to
say it was it was wrongfully or
rightfully so but it just generally as a
fact he's been scrutinized a lot on the
internet Piers Morgan show
all these different places you know it
it has to take a mental toll on somebody
eventually and I think it has for him at
least to a certain extent so if Muslims
are going to jump on this now and and
push them more and more and more it's
going to make it worse and if we want to
be the best Muslims we could be we could
support them kindly gently softly from a
distance and he has Brothers around 100
as we saw
who are encouraging him basically to
learn more about Islam and stuff
what a beautiful point I added on and
just to just to add to that bro just add
to that gem Romney there's there's this
analogy this thought exercise that I
want to kind of get the viewers to go
through but I don't want to compare dawa
to sales right but essentially we are
both trying to call to one thing so when
you look at sales let's say you walk
into like a perfume store you know or
like a watch store and someone comes to
you you know and instead of kind of like
you know showing you you know and
presenting them uh presenting the the
consumer to the market with like you
know we have this watch or we have this
this perfume you know instead of just
doing that and leaving it that they're a
little bit too pushy they're a little
bit too pressurey it's a little bit too
gimmicky almost you know I'm not and I'm
not saying you know it's it's you know
one one equals the other I'm not saying
we as in in duat we shouldn't be you
know inviting to Islam but there's a
difference between presenting Islam and
leading by example and doing that versus
kind of like just pressuring people down
and putting it down people's throats you
know what I mean and you'll see this too
I want you guys to think of any salesman
bro any anyone that's kind of like
overly you know try like they need your
money you know what I mean it kind of
puts you off in a way and it kind of
makes you even resist what they're
trying to sell even if you initially
wanted it bro you're gonna be like you
know what I don't know like what's the
catch now you know why is he like
insisting that I have it does he need to
like is there something wrong with it is
there something is it sus you know and
even in the worst case scenario most of
the time it won't even work but even if
they accept it now and they buy this
thing from you you'll never know if they
generally wanted to buy from you or if
they just did it out of pressure and as
Muslims bro the last thing we want to do
is get the shahada as if it's like some
like w you know oh WT W shahada it's
like no bro it doesn't end at that I'd
rather have a quality Muslim than like a
quantity Muslim you know what I mean a
shahada is worthless if they don't
actually believe in it and once they
actually become Muslim They Don't Really
practice it you know what I mean so at
the end of the day we should let take it
for his own pace and the best thing we
can do as Muslims if we really want
educate and other people to convert to
Islam and accept the truth is make the
world sincerely for him that's all we
could do bro because that is not from us
it's from Allah
100 that's very true that's very true
and um
you know last note last thing I want to
say is that you'll see a lot of people
you know like even myself I'm very
Hands-On you know I like to get involved
I like to be there I like to help
um but you have to know when you can and
when you can't
and this is not one of those times where
everyone and their mom can just send him
a DM or maybe I should say I have one of
their dad can just send him a d I'm
giving them advice or whatever you know
um maybe words of encouragement okay but
advice or arguments enough stuff it's
going to be you know too much uh he has
Muslims around alhamdulillah
um you know let's let's just like the
brother said like father said make dot
for him inshallah and then leave in the
hands of Allah because even if the whole
world came towards him to invite him to
Islam uh he won't accept it unless Allah
Wills right and even if the whole world
went against him and saying if you
become Muslim we're going to do this and
this and that then uh if Allah
and that's literally from the Quran bro
yeah so inshallah we'll wrap it up with
that bro should although that being said
and just for the special t3m family that
made it this far stay tuned for this
Tuesday inshallah we got the translator
of the clear Quran
on the show inshallah the real one you
know
um inshallah stay tuned for that